[Music]
5 47 into Wednesday morning what's
driving you crazy well we can confirm
substantial progress in the speedway
Bowl
about a week ago viewer David wrote on
Northbound I-15 at the 215 Northern
Beltway when is this project going to be
done I thought it was supposed to be
back to two lanes in early November
well David the Nevada Department of
transportation's Justin Hopkins said a
note right after I got yours mentioning
that that flyover from the north 15 to
go West on the 215 was about to reopen
which it did a few days ago
and while the entire Speedway Bowl endot
actually calls it the I-15 north quarter
project it's not done done but Hopkins
says it is on track for what they call
substantial completion by the end of the
year going to make it a lot easier to
get to and from the 15 and the 215 near
the Las Vegas Motor Speedway especially
when all the construction equipment's
cleared up thanks for riding buckle up
drive carefully please put down that
phone you can join the driving you crazy
conversation at traffic eight at
eightnewsnow.com